تعرف عليها على فيسبوك احبها وقرر الزواج
منها لكن مفاجاه كبيره كانت بانتظاره فما
القصه
[موسيقى]
واقعه غريبه شهدتها منطقه فيصل بمحافظه
الجيزه شاب يدعى حسام يبلغ من العمر 28
عاما تعرف على شابه عبر فيسبوك ودخل في
علاقه حب وقررات زواج
تم كتب الكتاب ونشر الزوج صوره مع العروس
عبر مواقع التواصل لتاتيه المفاجاه غير
الساره
[موسيقى]
المفاجاه كانت ان العروسه متزوجه وقد رفعت
دعوه خلع بحق شخص اخر اي زوجها
[موسيقى]
قصته لموقع القاهره 24 وقال ان اهل العروس
طلبوا منه توقيع على ايصال امانه لاتم
بعدها كتبو الكتاب
باحد الاشخاص يخبره بانه كان الزوج السابق
لعروسه
[موسيقى]
قال حسام تحققت من الامر وواجهت عروس
بالامر ورغم فيها الا ان الحقيقه ظهرت وهي
انها كانت متزوجه زواجا شرعيا